welcome to Miami and it is opening night
but the Jonas Brothers World Tour
happiness begins right yes and only et
is going to take you backstage you guys
ready we're ready ready
[Music]
it has been six years since you guys
have been together going out on tour how
does it feel when you look there and you
see that you're back together it's an
incredible feeling and and you know this
this tour in a lot of ways was kind of
the perfect storm everything between
sucker and cool the other songs in the
record coming out I think all of it was
kind of pointing towards this moment to
be back on stage together see our fans
we haven't seen in six seven years and
there's a magic to it that we can't
explain we'll just fulfill that we're
kicking this thing off I remember
sitting down with you guys for the movie
with Europe wow what a difference it
what is different this time to back back
there's quite a bit I'd say our hair is
a little shorter yeah yeah yeah yeah the
hair was yeah the pants are a little bit
looser I don't know they're still pretty
skinny their skinny jeans still button
our voices may be hurt a little bit
different deeper voices but the songs
are still there is that crazy now but
all of you like once upon a time was
just like the boys your parents right
and brother going on the road down you
have like the why it's an army kids yeah
it's crazy in yesterday the girls showed
up for the my growth I showed up for the
first time to see in the backstage and
you know I had to give them some special
stuff for the road and they were in the
best mood I think they've ever been so
I'm just beyond excited to have them see
this for the first night tonight for
more of our exclusive behind-the-scenes
from backstage of the jonas brothers
happiness begins tour tune in to ET
Thursday August 8
[Music]